national masters james canton iii here
with chess.com
and today we have game of the day with
the white pieces we have stock fish
and with the black pieces we have leela
chess zero
let's get right into it here we go we
have e4 on the board
and c5 as sicilian you know there's many
types let's see which one we have today
knight f3 and e6 so still not saying
anything yet sort of a normal variation
or the french kind of
sicilian after e6 there's d4 captures
captures all regular stuff and then a6
which is more of the
con sicilian with this a6 move actually
what you're doing is preparing an early
b5 is sometimes favored night or
positions
cheveningen variations very flexible
variations here with the fl
with econ early a6 intending in early b5
knight to c3 standard development and b5
does happen so we put the bishop on b7
here
keeping development in fact in every
opening it's almost exactly the same
when it comes to the first stage
which is getting the pieces out after b5
there's bishop to d3 developing
preparing to castle
bishop b7 we do exactly that castling
from stock fish
b4 attacking the knight and this bishop
on d3 is definitely defending on e4
so we actually don't have to worry about
losing upon after we move this knight
because we should because it's attacked
so you got two moves 94 or really three
knight b1 and knight to e2
knight b1 that's not a move why would we
go knight to b1
not a fun place to be in fact 92 or
knight a4 are the only moves
or the best moves in this position
actually which one would you choose
which one do you think stockholders
chose
in this position
well stockfish actually chose knight a4
and of course a lot of us would have
probably chose knight to e2 which is
actually an
alternative preparing to go knight g3
playing f4 and f5 and trying to attack
the king side of the board
but this one here shows a lot of
calculation and actually of course uh
the the engines are
as strong as calculation gets but knight
to a4 was the move here
knight a4 has a lot of depth to it so
we'll talk about that in a minute after
knight to c6 there's bishop e3
so now pieces work together so usually
it takes
three or more pieces for a successful
attack usually there's always
exceptions in chess back rank mates one
piece mates
two piece mates things like that but
usually generally speaking
it usually takes three three or more
pieces for a successful attack so with
this knight on a4 and his bishop on e3
if this knight happens to move we'll
check this out guys the b6 square
is now ours we have something to do with
this b6 square so it makes a lot of
sense
now after bishop to e3 there's knight to
f6 attacking the e4 pawn but not really
it's really preparing d5 and there's a
rule that they say to take is a mistake
what that means is
if i capture or before i capture if i
see any captures of course i should
calculate them
but i should always be asking myself is
it better for my me or is it better for
my opponent
when i make this move when i make this
capture here so there was no capture on
c6
of course maybe you can help the bishop
open up and there's no capture on d4
because you'll be able to help
these pieces coordinate just a little
bit better so you have to definitely ask
ask that question when um when you have
uh exchanges available so
knight f6 uh kind of attacking e4 maybe
d5 you also just need to develop like
you have to get your pieces out
so knight to b3 we go knight b3 very
nice move here the c5 square is ours
and b6 as well so hence the move knight
a4 you can just draw the arrows and see
the harmonious place pieces that white
has in this position
now black has a lot of flexibility but
again white's just probably the favor
here especially with
holes in the position right now that uh
black may have so knight to b3
d6 is on the board and f4 one of the
moves that you usually play in all
cecilia in fact there's a lot of
sicilian
theory that and as white where you can
literally just play knight f3
d4 trade castle and end up playing f4
very quickly
and every sicilian almost is exactly the
same with that but
here as we see f4 is push you want to
open a file with a smile here
and play f5 and also maybe try to trade
maybe carve some squares here with the
d5 square being weak
maybe g4 g5 work at free rook h3 like
all kind of things happen with this f4
move
also prophylactically even playing king
h1 uh dodging any type of checks or any
type of uh
issues on this diagonal f4 bishop e7
we're trying to castle and queen e2
centralizing the queen and connecting
the rooks we're fully developed
it's time to go to work usually the rule
is when you castle this game time and by
game time oh it's time to go to work
after queenie ii castle's work a to d1
son
very nice here actually put an x-ray on
the queen very good stuff here
and of course uh i honestly white's just
the favorite in this position more space
activity now we need to create a plan
rick a to d1 rook to ba
of course just putting a bit the rook on
a good file here defending the pawn
indirectly
and also defending the bishop that may
be loose loose pieces lose games
and by loose we mean undefended rook b8
there is a c4 here very strong and
interesting move actually
e4 puts a grip on the d5 square saying
hey
i know that your source of counter play
is usually d5 so before i do anything
else
that i want to do i'm going to stop what
you want to do so d5 actually was to
move the black wanted to play eventually
and probably take back with the knight
so we don't have an isolated pawn in the
center so c4 was extremely strong here
just putting a bind in a way a delayed
moroxy bind here which is very very nice
for white after the c4 move there's e5
saying okay i can't play d5
but i can play e5 so we played e5 and
actually d5
is now a huge hole here in black's
position
after e5 again what do we say um you
know to take is a mistake
so capturing would just kind of go right
into what black wants in fact if
captures
then the bishop is able to get open just
a little bit and get some squares
because this bishop is pretty gross
right now but after knight to b6
we put the knight into position so we
can swing around to d5 and we live
he takes f4 for the score and we take
back with the rook instead of the bishop
because bishop takes
is a fatal error start a new game so
rook takes f4
actually now we can double the rooks
honestly white is again the favorite
here but there's a lot of accuracy
we're going to fly through some moves
towards the end because this is a long
game actually
rick takes f4 and a5 so a5 threatening
a4
now of course when you find a good move
you look for a better one you have moves
you could play a4 you could move the
knight already
maybe move the queen maybe double the
rooks but what white shows here was just
say hey we're going to take the square
that we wanted in the first place that's
why we put the knight on b6
so we play knight to d5 very strong move
put the knight in the center of the
board
after knight to d5 you have the early or
the uh not early but just moving out of
the way
sidestepping this knight d5 move by
playing 97 themselves of course to take
is a mistake was the rule
so they say if you take it's usually a
mistake like how is it going to help
your position if you take this knife
it actually opens the bishop file for uh
for white and white's doing excellent in
this position so knight to d5
knight to d7 get out of the way have a
nice day and then we go bishop c2
by stockfish so backing it up e5 can be
a thing
opening the file maybe put the queen on
d3 in many cases
lots of flexibility and that's what
happens when you have space
so bishop c2 bishop g5 we got to get
some things off the board
and again we just mentioned space right
so what do you do when you don't have
space
well you should be looking to trade
pieces bishop g5 excellent move trying
to trade some pieces
rook g4 we do exactly what we came to do
trade the piece
bishop takes we take with the knight and
almost night night okay night f5 and we
live
rook takes d6 is in the mix and you in
some trouble on the double
so okay now uh knight t knight takes c3
g6 here just uh stopping any type of
play knight f5 is extremely annoying
so what do we do damn there it is thank
you for that pawn
appreciate you very much rick takes d6
knight c to e5
attacking his rook and rook backs up to
g3 we just got to get out of the way
it's pretty obvious the rook is hanging
so move the rook pretty obvious here now
after rook to g3 there's a a4
attacking the knight and in this
position we just move the knight
honestly just get the knight out of the
way knight's d4 and this is where it's
about to get very wild this is a very
huge focus point here
on this game after knight to d4 there
was queen to c7 saying hey
you have crossed the line what's the
line anything five to eight
is all black's position anything one two
four is all white's position anything
that crosses that is not my piece
needs to go you cross the line you gotta
get out of here
so queen to c7 attacks the rook we can't
play something like knight to b5
but in this position pause the video if
you'd like and what would you do
how would you proceed here maybe moving
the rook or defending with knight b5
what would you do
well let's take a look here stockfish
actually chose instead of knight to b5
it's uh
knight ef5 and we live whoa that's a big
boy move uh oh
you know it gets scary when the engine
starts to make moves
like this one knight e to f5 and they're
like okay hey hold up
what you doing here what are you doing
first off exploiting the pen and
bringing the knight a little bit closer
to the king
but no real threats yet nothing there
but it is a scary looking move
so knight e to f5 and of course when we
cross the line they gotta go
but black says well before you go let me
just take this freebie over here knight
takes c4
even the score a little bit because i
was actually down upon
says black and now we're actually
hitting this rook but
okay you know what instead of moving my
rook or actually capturing in fact i
don't even have any rook moves if you
think about it but knight b5 is a move
as well
but after this move what would you play
now white
to move what do you do i'm assuming what
knight b5 right or rook takes d7
well let me tell you something here
actually some of the best defense
is offense watch this queen h5 and we
live what you thought i was going to
move the rook
no it's stock fish queen h5 beautiful
move here
saying take the rook i dare you and
leela chess says
oh i will you're just going to show me
today we're either going to win
or we're not knight takes d6 going for
it saying hey
you're going to have to show me big
fella and here it is how do you finish
this off
pause the video if you need to but how
do you finish the attack you just gave
up a full rook
so you need to be sure about this or
else it's night night
okay knight takes d6 queen h6 you want
to keep the attack going it's made on g7
so we have to do something about the
mate the only move or one of the best
moves i think this is the only one right
besides knight takes f5
you know that that doesn't work actually
after rook h3 eventually
97 is also an alternative mate after
queen e5 and rook h3
nuts but 98 is defending g7 okay so
after 98
again it's on younow how do you finish
this out hopefully you did your tactics
today and your puzzle rush
why to move what do you do
here it is 97 check flex real hard
okay king has to go to the corner right
king h8 and now you know
how many pieces remember this is a pop
quiz when we said this earlier
how many pieces does it take for a
successful attack usually
how many three hopefully said three it
can be two it can be one but those are
rare occasions
but usually three or more queen takes f8
is not great
in fact it's blocking with your face it
is not a thing queen takes f8 is not
made after knight takes f8
and they're copying all the way home and
laughing at you while they're doing it
but king h8 is the only move in this
position so how do we proceed
we have to make sure that you keep more
pieces in the game so we actually
bring the other one bring the buddy to
the party
oh yeah it's going down so after knight
d to f5 here guys check this move out
what happens on queen takes c2 right
queen takes c2 you're like oh
snap i'm not mating what did i do
i gave up a rook i gave up a bishop and
i don't have
mates what do i do here you
tell me what the move is in this
position
here it is i hope you're ready for bam
oh my goodness
fall out the chair queen takes h7 queen
sack for mate
is always great that's a wrap there king
takes and
rook h3 start a new one you have no
moves you literally can't move anywhere
start a new game gg
all that other good stuff that was
beautiful so that actually didn't happen
in fact this is what happened here and
there's still a lot of chess left so
we're going to zoom through in a minute
but queen takes g3 was the move here
because there was nothing else to do in
fact you had no other move but to sack
the queen or you made it
queen takes g3 knight takes g3 and black
did a great job holding on actually b3
b3 a takes b3 knight e to f6 here um
just kind of developing this game is not
over yet no
i mean white is winning but it's not
over yet in fact right now
the engine says that the evaluation is
like plus one yeah okay
white's slightly better winning but it's
plus one that's like one pawn
you know that's not a lot even though
the queen is off the board for black so
h3 is on the board here stopping knight
g4
kind of stuff and just maybe making some
looks for the king a takes b3 and bishop
takes b3
so we get the bishop here let's fast
forward slightly rook after e8 e5
hitting the knight knight to e4 stepping
out of the way
and actually though we just real quick
if if rook takes c7 we want to show this
because
black has an extra piece so we want to
see if we can do anything about this
um oops sorry rick takes and then uh e
takes f6 knight takes f6 and knight f5
ouch with queen f6 and queen g7
queen g7 and knight takes e7 that's
beautiful
but actually after e5 there was just 94
get above the way
okay e6 here threatening the knight and
the pawn at the same time so rook takes
c7 happen
and then knight takes e4 you always got
to keep the threats flowing
keep them flowing bishop takes and now
queen h4 attacking the bishop
and the rook at the same time white has
to be extremely careful here
of not to trade everything because a
queen if black is left with two brooks
and one of these pieces in fact black
might be the one winning so you have to
be careful of what the compensation
looks like yes i'm down a queen or an
exchange not really a queen
but what is my compensation and
compensation for black would be the two
rooks
which actually equal more than the queen
five plus five right
so and and the extra piece which is even
more except just the king safety's kind
of loose
but black wins many more times than not
with the extra pieces
over the queen so we have to be careful
this white queen h4
hitting an exit g5 which is a cool move
just kind of getting out of the way
because there was three pieces hanging i
mean
this is hanging this is hanging and this
is hanging
oh this is hanging oh that's hanging too
but g5 queen takes c4
and then uh f takes c6 of course if rook
takes there's actually this really cool
move where you can take on d7
and then check and promote and then come
back and gobble some pawns still got to
be careful because those two rooks are
on the board but you do have a lot of
possibilities you also have a check as
well actually there was a better move
after rook takes there's this one rick
takes you have check
first and then taking on d7 so you don't
have to even um
repromote you actually win win easier
that way so uh
a queen takes e4 and then f takes e6 and
then bishop takes e6 and now we're going
to fast forward because this
is finesse here this takes some time
because well there's there's like
30 moves left from this position rick f8
queen d4 check knight f6 bishop b3 we
back it up
so we're keeping the files on lock here
as you see or the diagonals as you
see the king is very unsafe black's king
is very
very unsafe he has some problems so if
if the black king was very safe
in fact black might be winning but
because he's not you know the pieces
have to stay around his king
to avoid checks let's see what happens
rook e to e8 bishop e6 just moving out
of the way of the pawn
so we can advance it our job is to queen
asap rick d8 move the queen out of the
way queen c5
we're just trying to finesse like
maneuver around king h2
king g7 defending the knight and wants
this nice sequence here
queen c7 and then queen c6 hitting the
rook but not really
just playing queen c6 honestly and there
was a blunder actually king g7
runs in the queen b7 check and then bam
there it is give me something come here
give me something everything must go
sale something has to go
something has to go that's a double
attack there i appreciate you and then
rick takes the
or uh rook takes c6 because queen takes
his
check and that's devastating that's
going to lead to mate so rook takes e6
and now we got rid of one of the rooks
so now this is definitely losing no rick
and knight
especially with nothing against my king
now it's not going to work for black
let's see how the technique works kg7 b4
pushing that boy
king f7 and queen to d8 honestly
finessing
have to stay out of the way of checks
and forks
you got to be very careful here is white
so b5 we're still pushing
queen check you know what check again
thanks for the pawn appreciate it you
can have this one on the other side of
the board
and he does h4 which could be captured
um and in knight e5 and queen takes g5
knight f3 actually just loses
it just loses yeah you get the queen but
it's a winning king and pawn in game
very simple king d6 queen f5
rook b7 h5 we're going to queen one of
these walking the dogs in the park until
we clean something
rook f7 queen g5 rook f2 and queen d8
check
knight to d7 you have to be careful if
not to be checked with
by black and also you know guarding your
queen from from forks
and and weird things that can happen
rick f6 queen h8
and we're about to play h7 no way to
stop it h7 happens
and that's a wrap here check there was a
check here of course and there's now a
counter check happening king to g1 rook
g6
and we just step out of the way here was
good here was good i mean
probably all the way over here was good
didn't matter really queen c3
and there's another queen on the board
watch the flawless technique in the end
rook b6 queen eight three rick d6 queen
e3 should check
rookie six and this is a wrap queen g7
check
gotta move somewhere he just steps back
he's like you know what i'm done with
this
this is over why am i still making moves
zero didn't understand either so king e8
queen takes e6
king v8 and here it is queen ex d7
checkmate and wii greats
that's another beautiful game from
stockfish play uh playing leela chest
zero there nice sacrificial stuff there
pushing the pieces forward using the
space advantage and all those things i
hope you learned something from today's
video
i'm national master james canton iii
here with chess.com
and i'll see you guys on the next video